Let's look at the answer
to our miss rate quiz.
In a well designed cache, we want
the hit rate to be high as possible and
the miss rate to be low as
possible because the hit rate
determines how often do we
have just the hit latency and
the miss rate is how often we have
to pay the full memory latency.
So, we definitely want the hit rate
to be larger than the miss rate.
We definitely do not want the hit rate
to be smaller than the miss rate.
We don't want them to be equal to each
other, because that means half of
the time, we are going to memory,
we won't hit much more than that.
We want the hit rate to be
almost 1 because that means that
almost always we are going
to have a cache hit.
And we definitely do not want the miss
rate to be almost 1 because that means
that we are almost never
hitting in our cache.